saludos en este vídeo vamos a hablar de
algunas técnicas para restar números de
tres dígitos
digamos que queremos restar 357 menos
156 pausa en el vídeo y then si de
alguna manera pueden resolver esto
aunque no es necesario que lo hagan
porque lo vamos a resolver aquí paso a
paso pero no les hará daño intentarlo
vamos a resolverlo juntos una forma de
pensar en esto es que podemos
descomponer el 156 en sus diferentes
valores posicionales lo vemos como una
centena 56 esto puede describirse como
357 menos 100 una centena menos 50 que
son cinco decenas menos seis esto nos
ayuda pausa en el vídeo y traten de
encontrar a que es igual esto bueno
quizás varios de ustedes digan que si
tenemos tres centenas y 57 y si quitamos
una centena quedan dos centenas y 57 y
si ahora quitamos 50 a 256
tenemos 5 decenas y quitamos 5 decenas
que dan 0 decenas ahora quedan 207 ahora
al 207 le quitamos 6 y nos queda 201
acabamos de quitar 6 unidades de 7
unidades que teníamos en el 207 de aquí
y nos queda 201 esta es una técnica muy
buena para poder restar números y esta
no sólo aplica para números de tres
dígitos aplica para números de varios
dígitos pero hay otras cosas que podemos
hacer podríamos por ejemplo tratar de
ajustar los números para facilitar la
resta por ejemplo podemos decir que
sería bueno que en lugar de restar 156
sólo restamos 150 y hay una forma de
hacer esto siempre que sumes orestes
algo a alguno de estos números tendrás
que sumar o restar lo mismo al otro
número y la diferencia será la misma hay
una situación en la que restamos 6 en
ambos números antes de tratar de
encontrar la diferencia vamos a
escribirlo
queremos restar 6 en ambos a que será
igual 357 menos 6 pues quitamos 6
unidades de las 7 unidades de aquí por
lo que queda 351 menos 156 menos 6 es
igual a 150 y probablemente para varios
de ustedes es mucho más fácil calcular
esta resta pueden darse cuenta de que
aquí hay tres centenas y si quitamos una
de esas centenas nos quedan dos centenas
sí tenemos cinco decenas y quitamos
cinco decenas entonces quedan cero
decenas y si tenemos una unidad y le
quitamos cero unidades queda una unidad
o podemos decir mira 300 menos 100 es
251 menos 50 es 1 esto es bastante útil
otra técnica es pensar que en lugar de
restar 156 porque no restar 160 en esta
situación lo que hacemos es sumar 4 en
ambos números
y sumar 4 en ambos que sucede ahora
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
cuánto es 357 4 357 más 3 es 360 más
otro 1 361 y si sumo 4 156 dará 160 y ya
que sumamos 4 en ambos números o sea
sumamos la misma cantidad en ambos
números la diferencia será la misma
veamos tres cientos menos un ciento da
200 y 61 menos 60 es igual a 1
todo esto es igual a 201 y ahora voy a
escribir todo esto que hice mentalmente
361 menos 100 y puedo descomponerlo por
completo como lo hice aquí arriba no
puedo descomponerlo parcialmente puedo
descomponer solamente los 100 y luego
descomponer el 60 pueden verlo como que
descompuse el 60 y no escribir las
unidades
361 menos 100 es 261 y a esto le
quitamos 60 por lo que nuevamente queda
201 la idea principal aquí es que hay
muchas formas diferentes de realizar las
restas sin importar cuántos dígitos
tengan esto te da un panorama de los
distintos métodos que hay y algunos de
estos serán más convenientes que otros
dependiendo de la situación y de cuáles
sean los números que estés trabajando